foreign
times
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
oh
I wanna survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
she's in here somewhere outside
[Music]
I've been held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
[Music]
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you have to trust me you'll be dangerous
risk it but if you pull this off you'll
never look over your shoulder again
[Music]
oh
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it off
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024
thank you